if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is
just dumps dumps
[Music]
[Music]
rushes
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
dumps dump big massive dumpsters
[Music]
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
[Music]
[Music]
elements of
bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
elements of bathrooms god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
all right this is stream number four
in three days that is an average of one
and one-third streams per day it is the
final day of cpac texas 2022
do not adjust your television do not
adjust your mobile phone or your
computer screen this is glenn beck that
is a metal eagle that is comically
oversized uh hanging from his neck and
we are moments away from former
president donald trump's i guess they're
calling it a speech then he went donald
trump yeah donald trump yeah and it's a
speech which i'm sure will be uh filled
with precise speech i've had more
investigations than jesse james billy
they could
no more drop by the drop boxes
exactly so here is the agenda let's take
a look at it we are now so
this is central time
so you have to understand it it is right
now 5 20 p.m central time so glenn beck
is currently speaking they're only
running about 10 or 15 minutes late
which in trump world is like
extraordinarily good
then kimberly guilfoyle will speak and
she will say uh i guess how the best is
yet to come let me see if i oh yeah the
best is yet to come okay then tudor
dixon will speak then carrie lake will
speak and then the failed former
president donald trump is going to be
delivering a tirade of some sort so
that's what we have to look forward to
here i want to welcome everybody of all
political orientations
sexual orientations
race
national origin
um sports allegiance
gamers and non-gamers alike
people who
like metallica and people who
don't like metallica everybody is
welcome here that being said if you
troll you're going to get banned
okay if you troll your oh by the way i
like metallica
i'm not i'm not saying it's like i'm
just saying whatever category
whatever identity
is absolutely welcome here okay i am pro
metallica
um yes all right i know many of you are
still
uh high on energy from yesterday's
record-setting 605
new members that came in during what was
an explosive and in some sense
horrifying stream yesterday
uh and we will see where we end up today
now i i want to show you guys something
i don't know about the oranges of this
i don't know if this is for real if it
was hacked at some point during cpac the
message we are all domestic terrorists
showed up on their center thing i don't
does anybody know if they were if it was
hacked and i don't know if it's
controlled by bluetooth or wi-fi or what
it what it is i don't know the backstory
and i'm so curious about it but very
much perfect we are all domestic
terrorists showing up on their center
curved screen
uh and at the back at the front of the
room as well
i love it it's not an incorrect message
it really isn't which is why i'm curious
what where it came from it's uh
fascinating fascinating stuff
let's see what else we have here is
lauren bo bear saying that falci must be
prosecuted
we need to investigate fauci we need to
defund fauci and we damn well need to
prosecute anthony fauci defund the 81
year old long time doctor on the brink
of retirement by the way
i just read richard preston's book
crisis in the red zone it's about the
2014 ebola outbreak
and
fauci is mentioned in the book because
he apparently he was
actually providing bedside care to a
nurse who contracted ebola in the united
states it's an incredible story
but yeah that's the guy we need to
prosecute
and investigate and all of the all of
that different stuff very very sick
people
um so we looked at that here's a stunt
with former vice president mike pence
pumping gas for people
[Music]
and he looks so at ease and everything
about this is so natural and genuine
yeah so quite a quite a political stunt
if there are crisis actors
it's those people right there right okay
so uh i mean like let's we don't want a
defamation suit or anything like that
here's something that happened at cpac i
don't even know what
hold on hold on do you like the trump
one i like the trumpet okay check this
out
hold on
what you got oh wait these are the
newsmax people on the left this is like
grant or greg stinkfield this is ed
henry i don't know who the woman on the
right
wait a is wait a second stitch field
trump one can you believe it gotta have
booty i knew that was the hat you know
what i found something better for you
okay okay get rid of the boot give me
that there you go we're gonna give you a
heel
this is the ultimate stinfield army it's
a trump deal but
remember guys money can't buy you class
money can't buy you class that's really
my takeaway from all of this stuff i
want to say a huge thank you to jason
sickmeyer and kevin gouldy
each of whom just gifted subscriptions
on my website putting us on the board at
two
also over on twitch memberships are
dumping in emily john the elder dragon
with a subscription and a gift
coffee nub has subscribed on twitch and
wes 98 has subscribed that puts us at
seven
the record for gifted subscriptions on
twitch is now
skittle stew and skittle stews alone 603
gifted subscriptions on twitch for
skittlestu
i'm inconsolable in second place with
555
and then david chadman in third place
with 363
s prez
is very close to getting into the bronze
position espres is at 320 gifted subs
another 43 would push espres into third
place and knock david chadman off of
there uh fatty mcblunt's also signing up
via twitch
number eight today and says let's go for
700 tonight i don't know that that will
happen
um also lauren mcrae helping us
with a subscription on the website
joinpakman.com
all right let me make sure my super
chats are properly configured here they
appear to be let's look at a couple of
other things from earlier today
from cpac and other
related related things
let's see what i've got
um
okay i'm gonna skip that that's too
stupid even even for a stupid stream
like this one
uh
there was a bunch of other stuff here
oh here's bannon bannon spoke
let's see what he had to say that's why
cash patel
this great patriot accident
people think cash is just a genius about
counterterrorism and national security
everything like that he is and he'll be
the head of the cia in the second term
but cash understands the administrative
state this is more than a bureaucracy
right this is an organic thing that's
grown it has its own do you think
anybody in the audience has any clue
what steve bannon is even talking about
i'm convinced that they're basically
just words meaningless word salads
that nobody they're not even it's not
even meant to be understood it's just
sort of like
are you on board or aren't you that's it
words meaning dictionaries no no no no
are you on board or are you not on board
let's see what else we have from
today um
carrie i just i r i have a really hard
time caring about carrie lake it's very
tough now if she becomes the next uh
governor of arizona it's gonna be a
different story
the republican civil war continues
here's matt gates and steve bannon
denouncing kevin mccarthy if anyone
posits to be the leader of our party and
our movement they cannot stand for the
swamp and the establishment and the
bureaucratic permanent state they have
to stand with us in exposing these
issues and if kevin mccarthy will not
allow us to be able to find out these
answers he should not be the leader of
the republican conference
what do you guys think about that
do we want jim jordan
yikes
that is that is very very dangerous
stuff extremely dangerous rhetoric all
right we are standing by here for the
next uh thing
which will be happening very very soon i
guess
uh on rumble
is where right side broadcasting is
carrying the speech
always curious what they're up to let's
see
that's night here's what they're up 50
dollars off we have extremely low
quantities and once they're gone they're
gone so extremely low quantities hey um
by the way
i have now thanks to small fuzzy moss
our new mic pillow clip now remember the
original machines clip is the following
one we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines but thanks to small
fuzzy moss pulling yesterday's clip i
also now have the following over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines
that is just genius
a comedic genius in spite of himself
it's really something else coming up
next will be
uh kimberly guilfoyle kimberly guilfoyle
will be coming up next and that should
be pretty wild the best is yet
to come thanks to joy kit
for the twitch prime subscription number
10
uh carrie lake oh they're skipping a
bunch of stuff that's interesting thank
you to denver mccarthy for the gifted
subscription on my website and juan for
the gifted subscription putting us at
12. remember that today's coupon code is
indict that's because all these people
should be in jail and you can sign up
with that coupon code on my website
joinpakman.com let's see what sort of
delusional rant carrie lake puts
together
[Music]
wow thank you so much
well
we won
and we will ban men oh my gosh it's so
good to see all you patriotic americans
i want to thank matt and mercedes
schlapp for inviting me back to cpac
there's no place in this world i'd
rather be than to share a stage with the
greatest president we've ever known
president donald j
trump
mexico
[Applause]
i just saw that amazing man backstage
he's so excited to come out and how many
how many of you were inspired by
president trump at some point in your
life
he inspired me
i would not be here without that man i
would not be on this stage when i walked
well no she used to be a democrat didn't
she come up with this whole new
character just as a as a sycophant sort
of uh act to god i had no idea that i
would ever end up right here i didn't
know what was in store for me i did not
i promise you this
i never imagined this
this is not what i thought i would be
doing we didn't either i walked away
and i truly handed my life over to god
one hundred percent
100
i walked away and i put out a video to
the people of arizona explaining to them
why i was no longer interested in
working in a field that had become
propaganda the fake news back there
i didn't i didn't care what they paid me
i didn't care how much they were willing
to throw at me i was no longer willing
to work for them this is literally
beyond parody people of this country
and we need more of them to walk away
so
an amazing thing happened after i put
that video out the people of arizona
arizona reached out to me and they they
asked me to run for office they
recruited me to run for office
and i agreed
but i didn't know how to run for office
i mean how many of you would know how to
run for office
so i called i'll never forget the day i
called the ac gop
i said how do i run for office what do i
do
and with tears in their eyes they said
to me sir we'll help you hey ladies why
don't you come over
and uh you know what i've got a crazy
idea
bring a bottle of wine i think you're
gonna need it
and come on over right now was this the
drag queen event that she's been
criticized as as being a hypocrite over
unpolitical people to run the most
exciting campaign in the country
and we won
we didn't play by the rules because
frankly i did not know what the rules
were
had no idea what they were
i would hear from high-priced political
consultants
whatever you do don't talk about the
election
i didn't listen to that
then they would say don't mention cobid
shots and don't mention the masks don't
talk about any of that
suffice to say i did not hire those
losers
wow
i ignored them i ignored all of them i
did it my way and i listened to the good
people of arizona and i stand before you
today the trump endorsed republican
nominee for governor of arizona
now thank god
i did not know what this would entail
back then
god only showed me a little part of the
path if he would have showed me the
whole darn thing i might not be standing
here because god works in mysterious
ways the endless attacks on myself
and my family my children
they would follow us they follow my
children
take pictures of them they park outside
of our house these people are evil
bastards
you get them kerry
just look at what they put president
trump and his family throughout for
seven
years you guys called he's got the
globalists against him
he's got the globalists against him he's
got the left against him
and he's even got some people in our own
party against him we call them the
rhinos
now listen
i feel for him because i actually got a
taste of it myself i actually kind of
understand what it feels like to be
president trump it's not fun
it's not fun at all
so one day i called him and i said i
said i don't know being 6'3 239 sounds
pretty good
and he stopped me right there and he
said carrie
don't stop that means you are directly
over the target
so i'm feeling pretty strong right now
but they tell me what's about to come at
me it's about to get even worse
even more painful
and you know what i say to them
bring it on
bring it on
okay
i welcome the vitriol
i welcome the strife i welcome the
attacks
and i welcome every bit of it with
ultimate gladness
you know why
because this fight before us proves to
us that god is with us he has chosen me
and he has chosen you
that wasn't my takeaway for one second
that god makes mistakes
you guys agree with that
[Applause]
he has placed each and every one of here
at this point in history because he
knows our strength he's placed us here
because he knows that we will be the
ones to save this great republic
absolutely
this is where it's going to get a little
difficult because i think we got to
start welcoming people in we got to
welcome in obviously any patriot who
loves this country right
you're welcome into the movement maybe i
don't know we're going to welcome the
conservatives but not just the
conservatives we've got to welcome in
the independence
lukewarm applause we need to welcome in
any democrat disillusioned with the dead
end ideas of the democrat party
audience is very shaky on that
and let me tell you there are millions
of them out there we've got to welcome
them into this party as they walk away
we need to say welcome to the republican
party the party of we the people
she gives me real i'd like to speak to
the manager vibes i don't know about you
i think it is a battle between left and
right but this is truly a battle between
those who want to save america and those
who want to destroy her that's where we
are at this moment
my question to you is are you in this
fight with us
are you ready to fight
because we need each and every person to
be in this foxhole with us we all have
to be willing to say take the same hits
that i've taken and that president trump
has taken yeah that means we got to be
god trump's backstage did you guys hear
that you've had to do that
a few people out here a few i see him
that's crazy
we got to be willing to put our paycheck
on the line i know how that feels it's
not fun
we have to be willing to be attacked
and we got to be willing to lose a
friend or two or 50 what a lunatic i
think i've lost about 150. there you go
we have to be willing to be kicked off
of twitter
oh don't worry you're getting kicked out
this founding fathers lost a lot more
than a twitter some of the
disinformation just part of this speech
would get her kicked off twitter hoods
they lost their fields they lost their
homes those were tortoises basically
saying we have to cancel ourselves to
then portray ourselves as the victims to
then win
some of them even gave their lives
fighting for this country
for them america was just an idea
right for us
america has been a reality and it is up
to us to ensure that america does not
become a memory
uh that's not that's not happening
anytime soon
this is our moment right now
to prove to our ancestors that their
struggles and losses
were not done in vain
it is our moment to prove right now how
much this country means to us right
and i'm willing to take that sacrifice
and i know that you in this room are
willing to what is she sacrificing again
my father was a history teacher high
school history teacher
and nobody looks back on history on
those who were unscathed they're not
even remembered
it is only those of us who have the
scars who will be remembered
those of us with the scars of battle
this is this is fully fully delusional
that will make history
we may have won this battle
and i want an epic battle in arizona
a lot of me me me energy here
we drove a stake through the heart of
the mccain machine
that
i felt like i had to wear garlic around
my neck when i did that
so my question is are you ready to fight
a few battles
yeah against you
we
need to fight like hell to take this
country back
i know that the man standing back there
is willing to do it
i know i'm in this battle and willing to
do it who is ready to rise up and go out
there and win this war to save america
let me hear you
[Applause]
thank
you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
a completely delusional speech i mean
trump might be able to outdo it but
completely delusional alex asks via
super chat david what shows you're
currently watching season four
of borgin
uh it's like a separate series almost
because it's been 10 years since the
first three seasons i can't recommend
borgin more highly it's sort of like the
danish house of cards in a way
let's say thank you to some people folks
we've got a goal of 100 and limited time
to do it thank you to foster
leslie colorado springs kiki's deli
weather boxer and head pats
putting us at 17
and then the following people signed up
on my website well denver mccarthy
gifting one two three four five
six memberships that's it denver thank
you for the gifts six memberships folks
remember we are an independent program
and we do truly depend on your support
this is stream number four in three days
i have an extremely small favor to ask
you i need 11 000 votes give me a break
it's a legal favor nothing like that
head on over to joinpakman.com
and get yourself a membership you can
use the coupon code indict here we go
coupon code indict
and that does beautiful hold on i
accidentally did my password so i messed
it up hold on here we go coupon code
indict
when you type that in
it becomes crazy and if you want an even
better discount
yes the coupon code obama is even more
criminally negligent let's put it that
way
i will thank every single one of you
every single one of you
and uh i hope to hear from you soon and
see your name soon other super chats i
think i missed oh by the way yeah we do
an extra show every single day called
the bonus show
alex jones hates the bonus show i'm not
even kidding it's not like oh yeah the
boy no no he he's attacked the bonus
show before oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad he
even called it predatory that is a
freaking predator right there and he
called me a loser pac-man's a loser
if alex jones hates it that much
it's at least worth looking at
that's my case that i'm making for you
today
okay all right other yeah the bonus show
may be canceled that the rate things are
going i understand it's absolutely
plausible
um donald trump will be speaking
momentarily it is cpac texas 2022.
it sounds to me like there's a little
too much cpac going on here
what's happening here
uh-oh that can only mean one thing soon
that country song is going to play and
then trump's going to come out i want to
say thanks to jason sickmeyer for
signing up for a membership at
joinedpakman.com and giving it away to
someone else that's always very much
appreciated jason thank you thank you
thank you
um
other streams coming up this week
nothing specific but there will be more
streams there will be more streams
um rumor has it alex jones next is going
to be defaming the bonus show yeah
that's i read the exact same thing i
don't think it'll be to the tune of 45
million
but maybe a couple maybe a couple
thanks to aaron bowman george hansen and
sean tedrow
all of whom just signed up at
joinpakman.com putting us at 27.
thanks to gamer bathwater for signing up
on my website new member number 28.
thanks to the great desiree de long
gifting yet another membership on my
website desiree has been gifting these
things like their penny candy and we
love it oh look at this look at this
introduction nation in decline
[Music]
we are a failing nation
i got gas
whoa
fresh vegetables
wow
interesting intro
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in over 40 years
where the stock market just finished the
worst first half of the year
in more than five decades elements of
medical
we're a nation that has the highest
energy cost in its history
and we are no longer energy independent
or
energy dominant which we were just two
short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela and saudi arabia for oil
we are a nation that surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers american
citizens and 85 billion what a crappy
montage thank you to christopher scott
and chris ducharme for signing up on my
website putting us at 31
which is i would argue a great number
also thanks over on twitch to henio
and fjorkum
for the twitch prime subscriptions
always appreciate those
nation that no longer has a
free and fair press
fake news is about all you get
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where was that real right there
that was weird
i did see i missed the super chat let me
see if i can get back to that
the super chats are just flying by trump
how do you spell ymca okay very good
very very clever
thanks to jordan tyler for signing up on
my website joinedpakman.com really
appreciate that also thanks to oh no
this is going to be
you know who i'm going to sound like
pronouncing some of these names hold on
do i have it here oh no i don't i'm
sorry
i don't have it um jacob
dujen hoover oh i am sorry jacob i
really appreciate your support but i
think i might have just butchered your
name
thanks also to taylor ragland
taylor just signed up on my website as
well and his new member number 36.
uh do we want to listen to this always
has become a joke
but soon we will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country
now there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge
[Music]
yeah no challenge other than trump
pronouncing pronouncing names off of a
teleprompter
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah never ever back down
we will never let you down as long as we
are confident and united
the tyrants we're fighting do not
stand even a little chance
because we welcome everybody from dgg
today over on twitch i presume great to
see everybody thanks to marsha havens
for signing up on my website very much
appreciate that marcia thank you
uh also thanks to denver mccarthy for
gifting another subscription
over on twitch three mayors has just
signed up i believe that it was kimberly
guilfoyle scheduled to speak but maybe
they they will bring trump on directly
jay
trump oh god
[Music]
yep there it is so they're i guess
they're skipping guilfoyle i don't know
if guilfoyle spoke earlier
or not
but uh there it is remember cpac is the
event at which trump will often hug a
flag
in an act of senseless nationalism
and very base pablum
not sure whether he will do it
tonight
since says if they keep up with this
introduction trump won't have anything
left to say when he gets on stage
wouldn't that be great i know
i know
one of the great things that happens is
when trump comes out and there's too
much songs still to play he awkwardly
kind of looks around and and doesn't
know what to do let's hope that happens
here
[Music]
[Music]
he has to just sit there and listen to
the song mr scott says david sir trump
forecast for tonight sweaty with a
chance of glitches gotta wait for the
whole song to play yeah look look at him
just playing it's super casual what's
happening
[Music]
[Music]
i've never seen it go on this long
thanks to ronald larmonden
and william mcrell for signing up on my
website new members 40 and 41 today also
a big thank you to danielle dantzler who
just gifted a subscription on my website
to a lucky recipient incredibly lucky
recipient and it looks like we are
slowly getting ready for donald trump to
start speaking
bummed that trump is starting already
says jason means my chances of hearing
another golden whitney voicemail are
slim to none yeah yesterday it got
really crazy with the whitney voicemails
it was crazy
[Music]
today
[Music]
thank you to jody lynn mayers for
signing up at jointpakman.com with the
coupon code obama
[Music]
[Applause]
also thanks to p rick murphy appreciate
that as well
will this go over or under 90 minutes
what do people think
thank you
well thank you very much and i'm
thrilled to be back in the great state
of texas and i'm thrilled he's already
sweaty and slurring i didn't expect that
in the first 10 seconds
the proud patriots here today are the
beating heart of the conservative
movement that's true the beating heart
it all started for me at cpac by the way
i don't know if anyone was there long
time ago
but they are incredible and the job
that's been done is unbelievable
you are the loyal defenders of our
heritage our liberty our culture our
constitution and our god-given rights
you never
stop fighting for america and i will
never ever stop fighting for you won't
happen
but let's begin this evening by showing
our appreciation to our two wonderful
hosts two incredible people
unbelievable patriots
a family
of young ladies that are even more
beautiful than they are i have to say it
they are beautiful
we just took pictures and it's great to
see
matt and mercedes schlapp
isn't that great guys
great job great job really incredible
thank you matt thanks mercedes and let's
also show our appreciation to
everyone at the american conservative
union who helps to put this event on
it's an incredible event including all
of the hard-working activists who
dedicate their lives
to preserving a thing called american
freedom
they're incredible people thank you
everybody
we're all so grateful to be joined by
representatives
ronnie jackson my doctor oh no
horrible delusional guy
he was the white house doctor he was a
great doctor you know he was a admiral
that's the guy who claimed trump was
63239 which we all know is very much not
true doesn't take a doctor to know that
and he sort of indicated doctor because
he loved looking at my body it was so
strong powerful
but he said i'm the healthiest president
that's ever lived
i was the healthiest i i said i like
this guy i don't know who the hell he is
at the time i said but i
and he said i'm gonna run for congress
and there were like 48 people running i
said ronnie you've never done this
before you know he's a great student in
annapolis a great everything everything
he did was great but he said i'm going
to run
i said well let's get you into the
runoff you needed two two out of 44.
and he made it and then i said you know
now we're getting close ronnie and let's
get you by the rhino and we got to buy
that rhino and here he is he's great we
love you ronnie great job thank you
another one who's a warrior and he's a
friend of mine an incredible man ralph
norman ralph
congressman
thank you ralph thank you
ralph taught me a lesson he was in a
race
and it was so one-sided
that everybody said we don't have to
vote for ralph
we don't have to vote he's going to win
by a landslide
so maybe we'll just go out to dinner and
then we'll go all right people in the
chat number one will trump tell the
story about when he met with abdul slash
muhammad depending on you know he'll
call him abdul or muhammad that's one
story second thing will trump talk about
teaching transgender
right here thank you beth
thank you beth
a man who's really courageous and a
really great guy and he loves florida
and he loves the country
matt gates oh
god
oh
that's not someone you want to be
supporting right now he's always working
and he does indeed fight for all of us
for freedom is what he fights with
lauren baubert i heard you speaking
lauren wow
i heard you speaking
that was something i said who the hell
is that out there louis laura
laura and she had one of the greatest
commercials she said yeah anybody can
enter my house then she takes out a gun
stop spinning it around
but he may not leave when trump talks
about you you must stand as he will uh
heap praise upon you
and i can say the same thing for
marjorie taylor green a real champion
yikes
and you know okc said jewish space laser
but there's muslim space lasers too and
there's christian and it's just a space
laser that's screaming for you marjorie
you know that
amazing really amazing thank you very
much and you're sitting next to matt
what a combination those two are well
[Applause]
they are something but they're they love
our country
congressional candidates now look at
this guy he looks like better than cary
grant do you remember cary grant today
we don't have cary grant and today we
have rosie o'donnell we have
what happened to cary grant and clark
gable and errol flynn but we have a guy
that looks just as good as them
and he's running and he's going to win
boheins
oh where is this guy
hi bo
great football player too great student
and a great
football player and kevin kylie kevin
where's kevin
[Applause]
great job kevin
a man who's one of the hottest
politicians in our country he's hot
married to an incredible woman
and
respected so much in north carolina and
anybody that sees him or knows him
they immediately say there's a man that
we want representing us lieutenant
governor north carolina mark robinson
for people wondering that's trump's
teleprompter there off to the side
remember barack obama was very very bad
for using a prompter and here is trump
using a prompter that really took this
country by storm not just
the state
but took the country by storm tudor
dixon governor of michigan soon to be we
hope straighten the state out let's hope
not
peter's fantastic tutor tudor dixon he's
right
know she recently lost her father very
recently and he's looking down he's
saying i'm so proud of my daughter i had
met him i guess that was his last
meeting right
and they were at mar-a-lago and father
was incredible great steel person he was
somebody that knew what china was doing
he knew more about china what they were
doing to us and devastation
and we put on those tariffs and those
tariffs work so good i hope they don't
terminate the channel
but your father's looking down on you
right now and he's so proud
he can believe it you know he can
believe it's not like he can he can
because he knew you better than anybody
so congratulations go get him
wow y'all got him
trump's really able to comfort people in
a way that is really a rare skill didn't
obey any of her orders
it was
she's the shutdown queen but everybody
was shut down by her husband he was out
there canoeing all by himself now
normally you wouldn't consider that a
bad thing but when nobody else is
allowed to do it it's not so good
so i think you're going to have a
fantastic success tutor
nominee for michigan attorney general
and i've known him for a long time he is
so tough
people are afraid to even be in the same
room with him attorney general he's
going to make sure that you're going to
have law and order and fair elections
and so many other things he is respected
by everybody in that state
matt diperno matt
that's an important race
[Applause]
and a person who you just saw one of the
hottest
politicians in this world i think at
this moment that i think it's going to
be that way for a long time she's
incredible i met her
and almost immediately i said this one
is incredible i'll never forget i was
in arizona and a lot of people there and
i was introducing some of the folks and
everybody was bored stiff i said this
place is dying common and i'm
introducing gubernatorial candidates and
it was like i said i got to get through
this this is very bad there were a lot
of candidates and then
i introduced this woman named carrie
lake and the place went crazy
right
the place went crazy
oh there's gill for you
see there's guilfoyle to the left of
kerry lake to our right to carry lakes
left and bro bear is right behind him
it's what what a combination of people
an absolutely incredible governor and
she'll be looking at everything they
need a good governor out there they're
going to look at all of it strongly
that's supposed to say that that's not
politically correct but i'll say it
anyway you don't mind
so carrie good luck out there and uh
we'll be out there we'll do a couple of
rallies we'll get 45 50 000 people
remember when i get 50 000 and i
couldn't fill up the eight circles and
they said he won oh you got to be pretty
good couldn't fill up eight circles and
he won
i don't think gary feels that way i
don't think a lot of people do that
state has such spirit it's incredible so
congratulations that's an unbelievable
win thank you good
a friend of mine and somebody who was
truly
one of the best he was so brave he was
so courageous uh ambassador rick
grinnell
so brave
dangerous guys
very dangerous
it was great
another one who's great he's tough he's
smart
he knows what's happening
and he's really been a friend to this
administration to my administration and
when the other side
saw him and a lot of times he and rick
worked together that was a duo when i
had a big problem i'd send the both of
them the thing i wonder about is like
imagine sitting through this and then
you you're in there you're there in
person
and you leave
do people actually say
man that that was so great remember
remember when trump like said the
people's names in the crowd or remember
when when trump said you shouldn't be
allowed to teach transgender man that
that was just so great
great job kesh
thank you and thank you rick
chairman of the japanese conservative
union jay aiba and also glenn beck
glenn beck
[Applause]
so i lost a great friend and
as you know the prime minister what a
great gentleman he was what a great man
he was we had a
an incredible relationship there was
nobody really like him and the job he
did for japan
so uh he's right now on greener fairways
you know he loved golf
and he could play golf too he was good
and we had a lot of fun together but
we've made a lot of great trump's
eulogizing someone you know it's going
to get weird it was incredible
and he is a man who will be greatly
missed greatly missed
i want to thank you for your
incredible support also
because i just walked in the door and
they told me i had this straw poll
what
oh i i just come in sir you won the
stroke ball i said i'd better damn win
that straw paul
sir sir now and uh done by
mclaughlin you know the mclaughlin
brothers are fantastic posters so it's
an honor
and uh i guess we had 69 percent and uh
99 approval why couldn't i get a hundred
why
99
wow when was the last time somebody had
a 99 approval that's pretty good thank
you there's many countries where it's
common north korea is one of them you
know
[Applause]
and second place was 24
and then you had them down in one and
most of them didn't get anything and not
that i want that to happen of course but
it's okay if it does
and a very special thanks and i do
really appreciate that matt because it's
a very you know yeah i just i do want to
warn people
at this point we are uh
we're 15 minutes in and the speech
hasn't even really started so this could
be a long one this country is that short
paul is a tremendous indicator of what's
happening in our country and a very
special thanks for the amazing support
from so many conservative hispanic
americans in the
americano
media straw poll i got 81
is that nice 81
with a second place finisher i don't
even know who it is second place
finisher was at 16. it's genuinely nuts
to be talking about your own polls
three months before an election in which
you're not even a candidate embraced the
republican party i say actually they've
embraced me not really the republicans
but
but i won't say that because i don't
want to get myself in trouble with matt
but
they really are they're incredible
people they're hard-working
unbelievable but i've been watching cpac
for years and
as you know it used to be very divided
yet ron paul and great guy ron paul a
little different
very much like his son rand do i also
like a lot but ron's a little different
a little difficult like rand
grant could be difficult but you know
when they're your friend they're your
friend but had the ron paul people you
had the bush people he really has a way
with words with these stories really
crafts incredible imagery
i don't know i i'm shocked to hear that
but now there's a great feeling of unity
you know when you see poll numbers like
that 99 approval there was no such thing
there was no such thing there was no
such thing when you see those numbers
there's a great feeling of unity
not only cpac but i think matt in the
republican party i think we have to do
what we have to do to bring our nation
back right
[Applause]
because we gather tonight our country is
being destroyed more from the inside
than out
america is on the edge of an abyss
and our movement is the only force on
earth
that can save it this movement right
here
what we do and the really funny thing is
look at how much trump criticizes people
who use teleprompters
his speeches are this bad with a
teleprompter imagine what a speech of
his would be like without a teleprompter
i've
frankly like never before
this is no time
for complacency we cannot be complacent
we have to seize this opportunity to
deal with the radical left
socialist
lunatics
and fascists
and we have to hit them very very hard
has to be a
crippling defeat because our country
cannot take it you remember when i was
campaigning
and again we did much better in the
second election than we did in the first
by many millions of uh it's much much
better but
i used to say
not thinking this could even be very
possible but it always had a chance it
will be venezuela
large-scale or venezuela on steroids
that's what's happening to our country
it's not even
thinkable
we have to take this chance to shatter
the corrupt washington establishment
once and for all
we have to run aggressive
the guy who lost by like a record eight
or nine million votes is explaining what
needs to happen and how they're gonna
win country that's what we want
and we have to
throw off the shackles of globalism and
reassert two very important words
globalism what the words are america
first it's a very simple thing we have
to put our country forward
we had that done and we were doing great
if we do this then not only will we
fire joe biden chuck schumer crazy nancy
pelosi
what was she doing in taiwan
everything she touches turns to
[Music]
bad i don't want to say it
because i don't want them to say he used
foul language you know
i don't want to say but it does it turns
bad too i got impeached twice she failed
twice
the woman brings chaos
and that's exactly what's happening
what's happened in china right now
what's happening in china and taiwan
with what's going on she played right
into their hands china now they have an
excuse to do whatever they're doing i
will tell you it would have never ever
happened in a million years
under trump i can tell you
we played right into their hands but we
will save our nation and american power
prosperity and prestige will come back
and it'll come back strongly
victory cannot come
a moment too soon
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done to our
country in less than two years
the contrast between the trump
administration's amazing success and the
biden administration's
breathtaking failure could not be more
stark
let's look at the facts
i got gasoline gasoline for cars put it
in i got gas very much
1.87 cents a gallon i got it down to
they have it now at five dollars six
dollars seven dollars a friend of mine
from california called me
this morning
he just paid eight dollars and 55 cents
he told me california and you'll follow
you'll follow it's not even believable
with the help of our great texas oil and
gas workers we achieved american energy
independence that we were even national
average just a hair over four dollars a
gallon the size of russia and saudi
arabia
combined we were going to be energy
dominant now the united states is
becoming a beggar for energy we're
begging
we gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation cuts in american history
that's why we had the job numbers and
don't forget you have not good job
numbers right now they're not counting
all of the millions of people that
aren't working yeah those people are
never counted
there there are extraordinarily good we
are essentially at full employment right
now the radical democrats now intend to
impose the biggest tax hike
think of this the biggest tax hike
in bad times
in american history this will be
what they're doing right now the biggest
tax hike there's no tax hikes on the
table right now the exact opposite of
what i did and they're working
feverishly to pile on more regulations
at levels never seen before
i asked a lot of the big companies a lot
of the biggest and best businessmen
what's more important the big tax cuts
that i got for the country to get it
going and we never had a country going
like we had before the china virus came
in we never had anything like it and
then we did it again
we did it again we did it twice the
stock market was actually higher
it was actually higher than it was pre
covered as they say kovid such a nice
name i wonder where they got it
mitch mcconnell got taken for a ride by
joe manchin and the group
and the great people of west virginia
have been seriously hurt by these
political and remember manchin was their
friend for so long finally a democrat
who can think critically and think for
himself now now mentions the enemy west
virginia out what he's done to west
virginia i don't believe
i don't believe they're going to stand
for it let's see what happens
and i said this was going to happen joe
manchin is devastating west virginia
kirsten cinema agreed to allow this
massive tax increase just yesterday
to go forward only provided that wall
streeters are allowed to keep their
current
carried interest provision it's a hell
of a provision in fact i had it ended
and then i ended up getting so much more
for it i would have terminated we were
all set to terminate but we got many
many other things for it they gave up
everything to keep it yeah so trump's
admitting he went forward as well
mansion
and cinema what happened we're trying to
figure out what the hell happened
where did this new philosophy come from
all of a sudden
48 hours
i think if this deal passes
they will both lose
their next election
i believe
i don't think so
west virginia and arizona will not stand
for what they did to them
and that includes the races that are
being run
right now they're not going to take it
and i told the old broken crow mitch
mcconnell that this was going to happen
no i said it i said it loud and clear
he should have never approved that fake
infrastructure deal never approved it he
approved that infrastructure deal for
trillions of dollars and 91 of it is
green new deal nonsense
there's only eight percent to nine
percent that's actually for
infrastructure but he said if we approve
this one they will never come back and
ask for more i said yes they will
and guess what they're voting on it now
so maybe this speech can stop him
because when manchin hears me say he's
going to lose west virginia and i'll go
down and campaign against him as hard as
anybody can
all
right i'd cover that
and when cinema
does that to arizona
and i will tell you we have a person
that i believe is going to be the next
governor i don't think she's going to
stand for it i don't think she's going
to stand for it
you know it's interesting with mansion
so i got along with them very well he
wanted to know jerry west could get the
presidential medal of freedom i said
jerry west great athlete could bob
koozie get one too
yeah bob cousy great right everybody
agrees he's loved the coach they got
along with him fantastically well
couldn't have been better called me all
the time we had a good relationship
and he said when the impeachment hoax
started
i would never vote against you you're a
great president i will never vote
against you and where we were counting
up the numbers which we won very easily
by the way
but when we were counting up the numbers
i say one democrat i know for sure
will never vote against me on
impeachment
is joe manchin
so they're taking the votes and he voted
against me
i said oh he must have made a mistake
perhaps he didn't know what they were
doing
but i said to mitch mcconnell that
he will do this and
he will hurt riveting story and by the
way
trump's so wealthy why can't he get a
suit that fits i just do not understand
it she's going to hurt everybody but
mitch mcconnell has heard our party very
badly
should have never happened
and i said it and i said it publicly
when they approve that horrible
infrastructure deal and then they go and
they do this and they're not finished
yet you know they still have a little
time left
but mcconnell is the most unpopular
politician in the country even more so
than crazy nancy pelosi
and something has to be done he raises
large campaign contributions for
senators and that's how he holds on it's
hard to imagine a more boring story it
really is senators who i'm very friendly
with which is most of them you saw the
vote
they call they say what do we do you
know all of a sudden they're offered 20
and it's hard for them to raise money
but mcconnell will offer them 20 million
because he raises all this money and he
offers them to many of the senators not
all of them
and they'll call me what do i do what do
i do i said take the money take it it's
all right don't worry about it
you'll end up
where he ends up take the money they
need it
but it's not a good thing and under the
trump administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world we
had no inflation
we had no inflation it was just nobody
could even believe it they
they wrote books and they're writing
books on it biden created the worst
inflation in 49 years 9.1 i believe it's
much higher than that by the way yeah
it's not it's going down um denver says
i think i'd hate trump slightly less if
he wore suits that fit i agree it's like
he comes out wearing this cape
and it just all seems even more crass
the pandemic we handed the radical
democrats the fastest economic recovery
ever recorded the history of our country
ever recorded
they've turned that
into two straight quarters of negative
economic growth
also known to spike their protestation
to the contrary as a recession
and just hope that the recession doesn't
turn into a depression because the way
they're doing things it could be a lot
worse than a recession
and the labor force participation is the
worst in many many decades that's
it's shocking to me that anyone even
tries that talking point it's been
debunked so many times but look at the
crowd he's speaking to of course they
fall for the labor force participation
talking point they had
they had equipment and they had rockets
and they had
bombs that they had no idea if they even
worked they were so old
it's all new
or newly renovated
and the power is greater than any power
ever in the history of our
country but in the history of this world
and we just hope it never gets used
and we created thing called space force
they smiled at it biden smiled at her he
seems to have almost no idea what he's
even reading off of the prompter
the crowd not exactly into the speech
nine years since air force has anything
like that been done 79 years air force
was the last one now at space force
remember the first day they laughed at
it oh space force they thought they were
going to end it and the public went
crazy because you people know much more
than they do
they surrendered our strength and our
our everything our dignity
and turned afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever seen
not the fact that we were leaving
because i was the one that got us down
to a small number of soldiers
but we were going to leave with
strength and with dignity and we were
going to keep bhagram not for
afghanistan but because china's nuclear
plants are
one hour away where they make their
nuclear weapons are we starting to get
close to the abdul story when the
workhorse says billions of dollars many
years ago i was going to keep bagram and
you know who's occupying bagram right
now china
and the fake news doesn't want to
mention it
china all the time china the way we left
was a virtual surrender when you leave
you don't take
your soldiers out first you take your
soldiers out last after
the americans get out
and you take your soldiers out after
your equipment is taken out and all of
that was happening this is the most
incredible blunder
and the fake news doesn't want to write
about it because that's bad for them
look you're not even here about so many
bad things you don't ever hear about him
anymore we created the safest
border in u.s history by far
by far
and now it's the worst border ever in
history there's never been a border like
it and that includes in my opinion third
world countries because there's no third
world country that would allow millions
of people to pour in they have no idea
last month
141
countries were represented not just your
three plus mexico
141 countries were represented with
people that came in illegally we're
going to be paying a price for this for
many years to come in terms of terrorism
and crime
we ended catch and release we deported
record numbers of illegal alien gang
members
and we built hundreds and hundreds of
miles of the border policy under trump
and biden is almost identical with the
difference that biden has reunited like
400
uh families that have been separated
from kids
and i want all of those suits
and then we started and we did some job
and that gave us these incredible
numbers that frankly everyone talks
about today
and the number of people coming in
that's not three million or four million
in my opinion it would be anywhere from
10 to 15 million people
this year 10 to 15 million people we
have no idea who the hell they are
i guess there must be like 100 million
undocumented immigrants here by now
and most of that got finished too
three weeks was all it would have taken
three weeks and it would have been
completed the extra edition that we
added very much a lie the border was the
best ever think of it it was the best
ever
i went to mexico
and i said to the president of mexico
who i like a lot he's a socialist but
i even like a couple of socialists in
the world about three
yeah but
they're mostly dictators that you're
going to have to give us 28 000 troops
to protect our border while we're
building the wall no no no i cannot do
that but you have to no no no i cannot
do that and we started a negotiation
a woman from the state department good
woman she said you won't ever get any of
these things i said to the border patrol
who's fantastic by the way
give me your top ten things
i said give me your top ten things that
you want
and they gave me 10 and we should do a
poll who's more bored by this speech
trump as he gives it or the audience oh
i get them all guaranteed guaranteed i
get them all
and she's smart she's a good woman by
the way but she's been doing this for 25
years she said you won't get anything
and what happened is
the top representative came in we met in
front of this woman and others
and i said you're going to have to give
us 28 000 troops you're going to have to
do a thing called remain in mexico in
other words people can no longer come
into our country you have to remain in
mexico hundreds of thousands of people
remain in mexico
in eight other things which in many ways
probably matt probably worse right
probably worse
and
i remember he laughed at me he said
we won't do this he thought i was crazy
i said no you're gonna do it you will
you do
no we won't do it we will not do that
we're not going to give you troops free
we're not going to give you troops so
we're not going to give you remain in
mexico why would we do such a thing i
keep turning up the audio by the way
i've got it boosted like 400 percent and
trump keeps speaking more and more
quietly just he's barely audible we'll
have a 25 tariff on it
and he said may i leave the room to make
a call i said
five minutes later he comes back
mr president we would be honored to
supply you with 28 000 soldiers
we would be honored to accept hundreds
of thousands of people all over mexico
and remain in mexico until we check them
out
it was uh pretty amazing we got all ten
things it took about five minutes took
longer to
create the piece of paper that he had
assigned than it did to
win the negotiation but we don't do that
too much
you know we have a big advantage over
china but people don't know it
we have an advantage over russia big big
but we don't know it nobody knows it
they don't know how to use it if they
did know it
if no one knows something does it really
get known
they've turned it into a nightmare so
quickly the election was rigged and
stolen and now our country is being
systematically destroyed here we go that
got him riot
and everybody knows it
and this corrupt january 6
of unselect people they're unselect they
never comment when i use it see unselect
committee but this corrupt group of
people these are the same people that
went after me for
the impeachment hoax number one number
two
the same people
adam shifty shift the same people they
look into the mics then they lose and
then they go on to the next one it's a
disgusting if they'd use the same
energy to go and make our country great
it would be an incredible thing but i
don't know if they can do that
but i ran twice i won twice and did much
better the second time that i did the
casual nature with which trump tells
monumental lies is really something for
psychologists to study
more votes than any sitting president in
the history of our country by far
and now we may have to do it again we
may have to do it again
i got gas
thank you thank you so sad what's
happened to our country we're like a
third world country in elections and
we're like a third world country on
airports have anybody been flying around
lately or trying
we're like third world
but first we have to win an
earth-shattering victory in 2022 we have
to do it coming up in november
so to win in this november this election
needs to be a national referendum on the
horrendous catastrophes the radical
democrats have inflicted on our country
the republican party needs to campaign
on a clear pledge that if they are
given power
they're going to fight with everything
they have to shut down the border stop
the crime wave beat inflation and hold
the biden administration uncountable
they have to hold it accountable
incountable job number one for the next
congress
thank you very much
job number one for the next congress
and the next president will be to
restore
public safety people are walking outside
and getting
shot in the head
because of the radical left's merciless
crusade to dismantle law enforcement in
america
our country is now does any democrat in
a position of power support defund the
police these are talking about it we're
talking about democracy
isn't it great and then they say
you had seven people killed in chicago
this weekend
you had 68 people shot
that's not democracy that's not what we
stand for if only we could do something
about the tool being used to shoot
people specialists fail to continue
their violent rampages against
the united states of america
entire communities are being torn to
shreds with stabbing shootings
stranglings rapes and murders
on that little piece we showed you did
you see the man with the knife in the
back did anybody see that
i looked at it i didn't notice it the
first time and i looked at it tonight
i'm getting ready to come on a knife
right in somebody's back
the streets of our democrat-run cities
are drenched with the blood of innocent
victims gun battles rage between
bloodthirsty street gangs
bullets tear into crowds at random
killing wonderful beautiful
little children that never even had a
chance
they're struck and they're killed and
carjackers lay in weight like predators
hunting their prey they want that car
they're going to take that car in
california
people are leaving the trunks of their
cars open
so criminals don't smash the windows
when they try to rob
their valuables they leave the trunk
open so that they don't break the car
and break the back of the car when they
try and steal the tire and what's ever
in the trunk so they just leave it open
take it but please don't destroy my car
in los angeles burglars are stalking
people
back to their homes
to clean out the entire house
at gunpoint they follow them
they live in beverly hills they live in
some nice community they follow them
back and they go into the house and they
do things that you don't want to know
about
and this has to stop and it has to stop
now
[Music]
the crowd we are going to make america
great again
but we have to make
america safe again first
it's time for leaders
who have the courage to say
what needs to be said
and do what needs to be done has to
happen it has to be happened that's why
when i see tutor
when i see carrie when i see the people
that are running
these people are not going to play games
they want to bring our country back
they're going to bring our country back
to repair the damage from democrats
gutting of police forces nationwide
defending the police how about that
defund the police imaginary well we
really didn't say that oh yeah they did
and now they're saying it again
never going to change the next congress
should spearhead the largest increase in
the hiring of police officers in
american history hiring tens of
thousands more officers nationwide
city trump will release that health care
bill today
alone let them do their job give them
back their respect they know what to do
we have to allow them to do it
look at this crowd
wow
horrible you know when i came out here a
little while ago
i have a consultant and he's a very nice
person he's a rhino
and he said to me sir i don't think you
should say that last statement
sir i think you should say it's really
not good i don't think it'll be that
popular
i said what you mean the fact that we
should let police do their job sir i
think it's probably not going to be
received well i don't even know what i'm
doing sir to let him do their job he's a
rhino but he's a nice person we'll
probably keep him on the payroll you
know
we need to return to the tried
and true strategy of a thing called stop
and frisk we have to take the guns away
from people that are criminals can you
imagine instead of taking guns away from
law abiding americans let's take them
away from the violent felons and career
criminals for a change
obviously they wouldn't allow ins guns
into this speech that would be very
dangerous need a no-holds-barred
national campaign to dismantle organized
crimes these are street crimes
organized crime today is on the streets
and this administration doesn't want to
talk about that crime
they want to talk about what they think
are other crimes and many people say
they're not crimes
we have to round up the drug dealers the
gang members and the dangerous offenders
charge them for their crimes
and get them either out of our country
and back to where they came from or put
them behind bars there you go
if you look at countries throughout the
world there's another thing please don't
say it sir
please sir
i've been doing this for 30 years sir
sir sir you're on the cover of time
magazine at least the wins is not too
good
please don't say it sir
if you look at countries throughout the
world the only ones that don't have a
drug problem are those that institute
the death penalty for drug dealers
oh here we go
this is trump's new shiny object death
penalty for drug dealers he'll often say
each drug dealer kills 500 people let's
see if he says it
when i was in china
and until the
plague came in
i had a very good relationship with
president xi we made a great trade deal
for our manufacturers and farmers but
after the plague i don't even talk about
that deal too much damage done but i had
a great relationship with president xi
of china
strong man
you could go all over hollywood you
couldn't get an actor to play the role
the president she
he's a great guy in many respects but he
he's not too in love with our country i
can tell you that
but i said very innocently
do you have a drug problem
first time ever
and he looked at me like what kind of a
stupid question is that
no i said president you have a drug
problem in china
no no
no i don't have it why would we have a
drug problem i said well what do you do
oh quick trial
quick draw i said what's a quick draw a
quick trial is
they bring
drug dealers quickly to trial
and if they're guilty it's immediate
execution now it sounds horrible
sounds horrible
that sounds horrible but
every drug dealer in this country they
say on average will kill at least 500
people some people think it's much
higher than that absurd so
you would stop it and i believe
if you interest you would have to be a
[ __ ] to believe that traffickers i
believe that
drug dealing would go down
fifty percent on day one
fifty percent i really believe that i
think
i think it goes down the day you
instituted it yeah
i'll tell you one thing if i'm a drug
dealer i'm going to say no thanks i'm
going someplace else
and so are other people in singapore you
see what's going on in singapore very
rich society very powerful on drugs they
have no drug problem whatsoever a lot of
money plenty of money to buy drugs they
have no drug problem they have the death
penalty for drug dealers
other countries likewise we form blue
ribbon committees
where we put our great first lady
melania
she's in charge
and she says to me sir
we have a blue ribbon committee headed
by the first lady and very nice people
fine fine people dilating social lights
if they ever met a real killer drug
dealer they have a metal challenge
these special lights that's funny
actually i think that would be the end
of them they'd say i'm not doing this
anymore
but we have blue ribbon committees
headed up by great people that really
are well-meaning
and we were and i will tell you our
first lady did a good job she worked
hard and we got drugs down
19
that's great but you know what that is
that's like nothing
and today it's worse than it's ever been
because the borders so open that not
only people are coming through and bad
ones criminals are emptying their jails
into our country but drugs are coming
into our country at a level that we've
never seen before fentanyl coming in
from china you know i was with chi and i
said listen you can't send fentanyl you
can't do it he was they were really
cutting down
they were really cutting down things
were going really well and then this
tragedy happened in november two years
ago tragedy it was a tragedy for our
country what happened
because of what's gone on all they had
to do was leave everything in place this
place was going so good
and
they couldn't help themselves what a
what a sad thing but when i see these
blue ribbon committees
it's just and everyone wants to get on
can i get on the blue ribbon
committee says the local architect
yeah
but they don't know what's happening
here no you need
the death penalty for drug dealers drugs
will go down immediately by 50 and
probably more
but you have to mean it and you have to
mean it that's crazy and when you look
at china and other places they don't
have a problem if they had that problem
they wouldn't be doing what they're
doing right now
and they weren't they had this problem
many many decades ago
and other countries far smaller were
able to invade them and take them over
because everybody was suffering from
drugs and they said we can't do this
so
it's not very politically correct to say
it
but you'll save millions and millions of
lives last year we lost probably 250 000
people to drugs 200 there's no war have
you worked war
these are numbers that are bigger
than war numbers
250 000 they say it's a hundred thousand
i say it's much more than that it's
probably much more than 250 000 but you
also have destroyed
millions and millions of families
throughout our nation because of
drugs
in places where there is a true
breakdown of the rule of law such as the
most dangerous neighborhoods in chicago
the next president should use every
power at his disposal to restore order
and if necessary that includes sending
in the national guard of the troops
very authoritarian speech for that
every american of every background
deserves to live
in safety and in peace every american
one of the things that we were saddled
with
and one of the hardest decisions i had
to make when i looked at some of these
cities that were run by democrats going
so bad so fast
i wanted to send in the guard i want to
send in the troops and sometimes i did
in minneapolis i sent in the troops and
saved the place
i was getting ready to send them in
seattle when
if you look at i guess it was antifa
took over a big portion you don't read
about that too much nothing happened to
those people or very little i think
nothing but they took over a big portion
of seattle the troops were ready to go
in and they heard that
all of a sudden they decided to leave
thank you very much for leaving
but you know the president is not
supposed to be doing that the president
is supposed to do it at the request of
the governor well when the governor was
a democrat or the mayors or democrats
they don't want any help under any
circumstances
very much like on january 6 where i
offered
nancy pelosi and the mayor of dc
from 10 to 20 000 troops there is no
evidence that he made such a request nor
such an offer no evidence whatsoever has
been found of that see it
and they turned it down and if they
didn't turn it down and kash patel is a
witness
right i think you can i can say you're a
witness but we have many other witnesses
to that 10 to 20 000 they turned it down
and had they not turned it down you
wouldn't have had january 6 as we know
it but the president
is not supposed to be
sending in it at well
i think the next time either we're going
for a very quick change or we're sending
them in because we're not going to let
chicago new york
los angeles portland to portland is they
don't even when the storefronts they
don't even use new storefronts you know
what they do they just put up wooden
barricades now for stores for the few
anybody know what on earth this guy is
talking about that have destroyed
that place that city it's also time to
take back our streets and public spaces
from the homeless and the drug addicted
and the dangerously deranged
because no
civilized society can allow this
depravity and squalor to continue you
can't let this happen
places like san francisco the backyard
of nancy pelosi
she by the way has a big wall around her
house you know that right
but
it's so bad it's gotten so bad people
are leaving
nobody wants to have
office space there who would want to
have an office space when you're walking
through
a lot of people that are unfortunate and
in many cases very sick
mentally ill
it's actually dangerous to walk into
your office
if liberal liberals think that it's
somehow compassionate
then
you're gonna have to let them invite the
homeless to camp in their backyards in
their homes and ruin their property and
attack their families and use drugs
where their children are trying to play
and all of a sudden that'll stop very
quickly the only way you're going to
remove the homeless encampments and
reclaim our downtowns
is to open up large parcels large tracts
of relatively inexpensive land on the
outer skirts of the various cities of
the tent and bring in medical
professionals psychiatrists
psychologists
and drug rehab specialists and create
ten cities you have to go they have
tents right now they're living in
tennessee move the homeless into tent
cities you don't have time
to build buildings
you can do that later but you have to
get the people off the tree we have to
bring back we have to reach for all the
talk about how democrats are going to
put people in camps trump's openly
suggesting it with obama at least you
had to like sort of
read between the lines trump's like no
we would make a tent camp and send all
the homeless people there lives back and
then come back
to where they want to be
and we'll bring a lot of them back they
will come back but right now nobody's
coming back you have no medical help you
have no nothing it's so dangerous those
streets los angeles is so bad
san francisco
every city that's run by democrats so
bad
we want them to succeed we want people
to succeed
but they cannot be allowed to turn every
sidewalk and public park into their
personal
campground it's so dangerous as everyone
here in texas knows firsthand
there is another horrific disaster we
must confront if we want to restore
safety in our country
at long last we must
stop the invasion at our southern border
it's an invasion our country is being
invaded
okay
our countries being invaded
just like a military force was pouring
in
just last month an illegal alien here in
texas was indicted for the cold-blooded
murders of four elderly women throughout
the state
and he's been accused of links to the
deaths of at least 24 people
24 people
perhaps the deadliest serial killer in
texas history they're now saying he
could be the deadliest
serial killer he's an illegal alien
earlier this year an illegal alien
fugitive with a prior arrest
for aggravated assault and many other
arrests
viciously shot and killed a harris
county police officer
at a traffic stop
no reason whatsoever none
and in new mexico last year an illegal
alien criminal out of jail
on unsecured bond
was charged with
decapitating a man
mutilating his body
and kicking his head around like a
soccer ball all over the public park
think of this
animals
never forget every death at the hands of
a criminal illegal alien
is entirely preventable this is all
understand that many such instances
happened while trump was president too
we remember kate
standing in san francisco with her
father we remember that
a man who came in
five times at least
and shot beautiful kate dead
republicans in congress must make clear
that on their watch not a single penny
of taxpayer money
will go to funding
joe biden's open border agenda it's a
sick agenda it's a sick agenda
makes no sense
and some things make sense you know i
understand the other side you always
have to understand the other side i
understand the other side open borders
there's nobody has open borders it makes
no sense you know we fight we don't
either and spend billions and billions
and even trillions of dollars
defending
the borders of countries that are 7 000
miles away
but they don't want to spend any money
to defend our border
makes no sense does it
next year we have to use the purse
strings to send a message
to every would-be illegal alien
all over the world
if you break into our country illegally
you will
be caught
we will detain you and we will quickly
send you back to the place from which
you came or put you in prison
immediately
and we did that we told people they
remember the
at the beginning we had these big
caravans we didn't have the caravans and
they already now they're starting at
caravans nobody's ever seen anything
like it we're within three months of an
election so now the caravans are
starting for us
because they would bring people into
guatemala
honduras el salvador and mexico
lesser extent
and they'd bring them back and they
wouldn't let us land the planes they
wouldn't let them have buses they
wouldn't let them come back into the
country so you'd have the worst gang
members of the world mostly ms-13
and if they came from honduras we
couldn't get them back and
i had some incredible people in my
office border patrol
people guys like also tom holman and
mark morgan
so many others these are great people
these are brave people
but
they'd be in and they'd say to me tell
me
uh we can't bring them back sir because
the country won't allow i said really
why won't they allow they won't allow
they don't want ms-13 back in their
country they force them out they put
them into caravans they force them out
and why wouldn't they how smart i mean
you don't have to be they don't want
them in their country
so what happens is i said all right good
how much money do we pay those three
countries
sir
we pay them 750 million dollars a year
that's a lot of money sir sir peanuts
compared to what we pay to some but
750 million i say that's all right
put out a notice immediately that we're
stopping payment we're not going to pay
anymore
and
trump knows about that
not paying people okay sir i don't think
it'll work we tried everything
that's why we kept them here because we
couldn't get them out that's all right
you let them know we're not going to pay
any more money to them
the following morning i had calls from
the three presidents of the country
president president
there seems to be a problem
our funds have been cut off yeah they've
been cut off because
you wouldn't allow these people back
that you probably pushed into our
country because you didn't want them
because they were criminals and they
were in jail in many cases you got to
take them back oh president this was
just a minor misunderstanding we would
love to have ms-13 come back into opera
and they took them back and we couldn't
get them out of here fast enough i will
tell you
that's true carrie terry will do it
carrie's going to stop him at the border
there's nobody coming in arizona that'll
be a
safe place again
this guy kelly by the way he's done
nothing
he's done nothing blake masters is going
to do a fantastic job carrie
kelly's got nothing going he should
probably wrap up the sp
excuse me also need a record increase in
the number of ice officers and border
patrol officers to resume the
enforcement of
our immigration excuse me he should
probably wrap up the speech
given that the crowd is dead 98 percent
of the time
illegal aliens out of our country in
addition we should pass much tougher
penalties for repeat immigration
violators of which there are many of
your a foreign national who repeatedly
tramples upon the laws of our nation
you should be looking
at spending a long time in jail we can't
do it anymore we can't do it we're like
it's kind of weird to propose so many
different things when you're not even a
candidate for anything nor on any ballot
upcoming we secure the border another
key priority for the next congress and
the next president
will be to
drain the swamp
once and for all
there's an idea
to remove rogue bureaucrats and root out
the deep state congress should pass
groundbreaking reform deep state
empowering the president to ensure that
any federal employee who is corrupt
incompetent or unnecessary for the job
can be told you're fired you ever hear
that you're fired yeah fire
our current appeals process to remove
these bureaucrats people that can really
be bad they can even be thieves
you can catch them stealing large sums
of money you have to go through a
three-stage appeals process
which takes on average five years per
stage 15 years you'll be gone you'll be
out of office by that time in other
words to fire someone who is doing a bad
job if the government wins
will take
more than a decade
under the current system
almost all politicians
won't start that process because they'll
be gone and they know it you know a lot
of politicians they go to washington
they're all set
and then they get caught up with people
that say hey i'll be here a hell of a
lot longer than you will and the
politician just goes about having nice
dinners
we can't do it anymore we got to run
this country properly
if only trump had had an opportunity to
prove to us that he would do all these
things
in washington d.c and we did a lot of it
but nobody knew that deep state was that
deep
fully conspiracy it's openly
conspiratorial now this is like infowars
with this deep state stuff so need to
take power back from the left-wing
lunatics who are indoctrinating our
youth oh
here we go we have to finally and
completely smash
the radical left's corrupt education
establishment the current
system is sick it's no teaching
transgender we're the lowest
scores almost in the world and we spend
more per pupil than any other nation
school prayer is banned but drag shows
are allowed
to permeate the whole place it's okay
you can't teach the bible but you can
teach children that america is evil
and that men
are able to get pregnant
whatever it takes conservatives must
liberate america's children from the
captivity of these marxist teachers
unions that's what they are where do
they come from marxism there's a topic
trump knows about
we need to defend parents rights think
of this
i gave a
talk
a few days ago and i was talking about
defending parents rights and i just said
you know his parents rights
they said can you imagine we're even
talk we are going to defend parents
rights did you ever think 10 years ago
five years ago that we would be fighting
for parents rights what's more basic
than parents rights especially parents
rights over their children we're trying
to defend
parents writes it's so crazy
across the country we need to implement
strict
prohibitions on teaching inappropriate
racial sexual and
political material to america's school
children in any form whatsoever and we
will bear and if federal bureaucrats are
going to push this radicalism we should
abolish
the department of education
how many people in the room do you think
know what the department of education
does
and we will keep men
out of women's sports
that's another one
and by the way we have a great person
here
where's our beautiful great swimmer
gaines wears gains look at come up here
will you please come up oh no come up
come on come on this is gonna be a
wildly transphobic few minutes is my
prediction
and she was beating everybody and then
one day she looked over and said that's
the largest human being i've ever seen
come here buckle up everybody
she's been so brave you know because a
lot of people say you can't talk about
it they told me please don't mention
that sir it's not politically correct
and i did about three weeks ago the
place went crazy it was the largest
applause i've ever heard trump was
shocked by how transphobic his own
supporters are he's like i had no idea
they were this transphobic
please say something about swimming
against that big evil person
basically all i want to say is that it
takes a brain and common sense and fifth
grade biology
level understanding to realize that this
is blatantly unfair um it's completely
obvious and so i spoke earlier today and
i i said a lot so
i'll keep it short and i'm just gonna
say keep female sports female
just to show you how ridiculous it is
is trump getting handsy with her a much
bigger and much stronger than her
there's no way she could beat me in
swimming do we all agree uh
thank you
it wouldn't be pretty i wouldn't invite
too many friends to that one but
right now but how ridiculous is it
really oh it's ridiculous
how ridiculous is it the weight lifters
they're lifting numbers they're breaking
the records by hundreds of pounds it's
ridiculous
and no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without parental consent
does anyone know what it means to teach
transgender could anybody explain that
to me um we need to get critical race
theory and left-wing gender ideology out
of our military i had it out
i had it out
the world is too dangerous for america's
armed forces to be politically correct
you look at what's happening with china
and russia
but you look at those
rockets going up one after another
and
we don't want to be politically correct
with our military we got to be tough can
you imagine george patton
you know he had
he had a very strong temper he was a
very violent man actually great general
violent kai
and he'd walk in and he'd be screaming
at people
they'd throw him out of the military
today because he wasn't nice
now we have to we have to get back to
running things you know i had it totally
out of the military i had it out of
government through executive order
and you couldn't get the democrats to go
along with it but it didn't matter i had
it totally out
one of the first things they signed back
in was that nonsense and we can't let
that happen
back over we have to take over
government we have to run it like it's
supposed to be wrong
we must also win the battle to restore
free speech in america
republicans across
these people have all lost their speech
rights
going after the new
[Music]
censorship regime is censorship
it's worse than it's ever been i've
never seen anything it used to be even
10 years ago because i was always very
active with different things
and i'd fight the media i'd say
something did you know you go back and
forth and you win you lose you like to
win but you win you lose
today they don't even talk about it
if you have anything to do with the
election they don't want to talk about
it if you have anything to do with
certain things they won't even talk
about they don't want to debate it
january 6 never brings up the election
which is the reason all of those people
were there they don't want to talk about
it
they don't want to look at the
corruption
that took place in arizona and all of
the states you saw in wisconsin i was in
with wisconsin
and it was an incredible group of people
but the nursing homes traditionally very
few people
vote this is where trump claims that
part of the fraud is that a nursing home
voted a hundred percent for biden or
something
and you know how they found out because
the children of elderly people in the
nursing homes were so angry my father
did not vote he's comatose
he's been sick he's ready to die he'll
be dead very soon he didn't vote
daughters and sons they were very angry
about that's how it started they have
justice gableman he came out with a
scathing report about how crooked the
election was
we should expose exactly what they're
doing
what they're hiding who they're
silencing and who is funding it all and
who is coordinating it
go out sign up now by the way for truth
social it's really great it's it's given
us a voice it's giving us our
voice of urgent tasks for the next
congress and the next president is
endless and
we do not have to
wait we have to move quickly we don't
have time to our country is
being shot
it's being destroyed
it's
something we have to do for the future
the future of our country is at stake
we don't have time to wait years and
years we won't have a country left what
i used to say about venezuela is true
we have to save the economy defeat the
biden pelosi schumer tax hike which is
happening right now tonight it's not
exactly it's already approved it's
non-existent and i do believe that
mansion and cinema will pay a big price
for it
but think of it this is the only group
they want to
do the biggest tax hike in history for
green new deal stuff
and
they're just destroying us when
everyone's doing so poorly on top of the
gasoline on top of the bacon which is
quadrupled
and stopped the out of control inflation
that is crushing american workers and
families it's crushing
never seen anything like it to bring
down energy prices
we have to abolish
the green new deal we don't have it it's
a fake it's a fake
it's a to bring energy prices back down
to where they were we have to abolish
something we don't have gates in my
administration and yet we were producing
more energy more oil more everything
than we've ever done before
instead of begging for oil from iran and
venezuela and other distant foreign
nations
we should be pumping it from
pennsylvania north dakota louisiana and
if you don't mind texas if you don't
mind
we should once again require able-bodied
single adults to go back to work or
train for a job in order to receive
welfare and taxpayer-funded benefits
there you go
we need the workers
we have to eliminate all remaining covet
mandates and lockdowns are there any
lockers and we have to rehire every
patriot who is fired from the military
with an apology and we have to is
anybody locked down right now
we have to restore america first
we have to go it's been going about 75
80 minutes so far foreign policy
we have to be america first right now we
are truly america last we are america
last
focus squarely on our national interests
and we have to keep the united states
out of these ridiculous endless
foreign wars
where they don't even want us
to build on my historically successful
trade policies we need to increase the
president's tariff power and we need to
make
my china tariffs permanent we took in
billions and billions hundreds of
billions of dollars no president has
taken in
10 cents not 10 cents
china doesn't like me too much
we need to hold on to
our dignity
and need to too late hold china
accountable for the unleashing of the
virus upon the world
50 trillion dollars of damage to the
world not us to the world
and we need to rapidly reduce our
dependence on china and other foreign
nations by bringing our supply chains
factories
and critical
industries back home where they belong
like it used to be
back to the future you know back to the
future all right what do you guys think
will he go more than 10 minutes from now
or or fewer than 10 minutes from now in
the speech remaining that now they're
sending it all back to other nations to
make for us and to make a tremendous
amount of money we have to protect our
totally under siege second amendment it
is under siege and restore the ancient
and sacred right to self-defense i'm
sorry it's an ancient right
one thing you know they take away your
guns they're not taking away the guns of
the bad guy are they they're not going
to take away the guns of the bad guy
none of them are giving up their guns
we have to defend our cherished
constitution and uphold our heritage as
a society built and sustained by
judeo-christian values
remember they mean christian values they
throw in the judeo to make themselves
not sound like the christian
nationalists that they are america
one standard of justice so unfair what's
going on
the weaponization
of law enforcement for political
purposes must end it must end
immediately
there is massive
prosecutorial misconduct going on right
now
all over our country
the likes of which has never been seen
before they've never seen anything like
what's going on right now
look at all the people who are in prison
or whose lives have been destroyed on
january 6 destroyed by their own doing a
protest over a rigged and stolen
election that nobody wants to look at
while others are allowed to burn down
cities and violently and viciously kill
people and nothing happens to them how
about that
prior to january 6th
i recommend it strongly we mentioned it
briefly before but i have to say it
again
that the national guard or troops be
brought in
but it was turned down by the d.c mayor
and nancy pelosi there is no evidence
that he made any such request no
evidence it appears to be completely
made up correct statement cash and rick
and everybody they're all there thank
you
they were all there nobody wants to talk
about it they never bring it up it's not
they don't
you know what else they don't want to
talk about
how about that phony story i'm sitting
in the back of the beast
i wasn't sure if i should be honored
because i felt very strong
and i had these two big strong secret
service guys if one guy could lift 350
pounds no problem
and i said take me to the capitol no sir
can't do it
so i grabbed this steering wheel
the comet did
and he rebuffed me she said he rebuffed
interesting where he rebuffed me yeah
like this
he rebuffed me
[Applause]
so my hands
fell around another powerful guy
strong as hell
i know these people these are very
strong people
it's just not my deal and i started to
choke him i felt you know when so when
the story came out remember she never
said anything about choke
[Applause]
some people said i never knew you were
that strong physically
[Applause]
and then they said i started throwing
food all over the white house no
i have too much respect for the white
house but that somebody could sort of
believe you know that you could
but to think that i'm going to be
jumping into the seat grabbing a will
being rebuffed grandma this big i'm more
convinced than ever the story is true
after watching the last three minutes
oh boy oh boy oh boy well we have to put
and and guess what
the secret service
put out an announcement which they never
do put out an announcement that it never
happened which everyone knew anyway they
were invited to testify under oath which
they said they were willing to do and
then nobody from the secret service
showed up to do it
because they don't want to hear that
and i still see the times writing about
it like it's something that happened
they don't want that they haven't called
anybody from the secret service to put
them on the stand
it's a disgrace what's going on it's a
one-sided witch-hunt that continues and
continues
as another example the sting that they
did involving gretchen whitmer
was fake
just like those who instigated january
6th it was a fake
deal fake
it was a fake how many conspiracy
theories has trump outlined today
gretchen whitmer was in less danger than
the people sitting in this room right
now it seems to me
and you look to see what happened and
trials are going on all over the place
and
i guess a lot of people tutor are being
exonerated aren't they huh they're being
exonerated
everywhere we have the chance we must
pass critical election integrity reforms
including universal voter id they don't
want a voter id
they don't want voter id under no it's
truly becoming the speech that will
never end let me see how long it's been
going now there's only one reason they
don't want voter id because they want to
cheat
they don't want citizenship confirmation
we're on minute 83 citizens we don't
want we want everybody to come and
think about those two things
no more fake drop boxes you see the drop
boxes in one case a hundred percent of
the vote
went to joe biden a hundred percent
that's not true and you saw two 000
mules i hope everybody said
i saw a
i saw that i looked at this movie then i
saw somebody being
interviewed by
fox unfortunately somebody named sandra
smith
and they talked about this
whole scam
don't forget the cameras have them and
these are government cameras some of
them were discarded by people illegally
but these are government cameras the
government and they talked about it well
they saw it they saw the stuffing they
saw everything looking up for the
cameras the way they came in they have
it perfectly on tape and she looks and
she goes oh that was debunked
it wasn't debunked how did they debunk
it bike they didn't debunk it
there was no debunking
it was debunked what's debunked they
have it on camera
it's bunk
well the woman in georgia that took the
massive number of ballots from under the
dress of the table right
and now
government's apologizing to her oh how
could she have been so
big massive dumb very interesting
that one's a very interesting one
because
remember they said there was a water
main break
a water main break everybody out they
don't talk about the real facts
dumb everybody out
got to get out they all run out then a
couple of a short time later
a small group comes back in they go
right for the table they don't go back
to the machine where they were which
would be more normal they go right for
the table the dress they lift that dress
up they grab that
group of ballots thousands of them
putting them in again and again
they call them dumb they said nothing
happened bill barr didn't want to be
impeached he didn't want to be impeached
how did you not get impeached nothing
happened i thought the election was fine
the
rather respected bill mcswain
you know the the
the respected
u.s attorney
from pennsylvania
mcswain
told me wanted my endorsement
because he was running for governor i
said i wouldn't endorse you for dog
catcher
because you didn't
and i didn't like saying this treated
him like a dog
because you didn't
do what you should have done which is go
into the election for it sir i wasn't
allowed to why
bill barr wouldn't let me i said put it
in writing he did he wrote me a letter i
put the letter up but they don't want to
print the letter a very strong letter
that bill barr would not let him look
into wrong corruption fraud in
philadelphia what are the most dishonest
election places in the country in
detroit
the single most dishonest
they found nothing wrong
it's a shame but
we want no private money pouring into
local election offices anymore think of
this zuckerberg
he put in
417 million dollars matt 417 million
and matt knows because he was involved
in nevada matt wasn't really you know he
was sort of on the edge not knows about
crimes he's committing them regularly
looking at nevada he said this is the
most corrupt thing i've ever seen but we
had a democrat judge he refused to even
look at the case the case was
ironclad he looked this case is over
it's a shame what's happening to our
country
a shame
our goal should be
same day voting with only paper ballots
trump voted early from florida into
florida by mail
only paper you know france just at
france which is a pretty big country
just had 55 million people vote all
paper ballots
all same-day voting
by 10 o'clock in the evening the
election was over
and the person that lost didn't go
around complaining it's on to the next
one i think that has more to do with the
fact that we have 50 different state
election systems than anything else that
could happen to our country
because we have to have honest elections
or we have to have borders or we don't
have a country
and if we do all this
if we stop the crime secure the border
save the economy defend our culture
and take back
our democracy then america first
conservatives will be rewarded with a
governing majority that will transform
american politics forever we're at such
an important point
the radical left
will be banished into
political
oblivion
we will save our freedom we will save
our children and we will save our
country
but the task will not be easy
together we are standing up against some
of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents
our people and our country has ever seen
a friend of mine recently said that i
was the most
persecuted person in the history of our
country
and then i thought about it
and i said i didn't have time to think
much because i'm always being persecuted
and i felt you know
he may very well be right
what a terrible thing
we had think of it a
russia-russia-russia scam i'm the
biggest victim that was covered
religiously by the
fake news media
even though they knew it was a fake they
knew it was fake they knew earlier than
anybody it turned out to be a concocted
fairy tale made up by crooked hillary
clinton the democrats a sleazeball
writer named christopher steele
and a coordinated effort this could only
happen to me with of all places you know
who coordinate russia
they were the ones that were involved
with the russia-russia-russia hoax on me
then i had
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two
mueller investigation resulting in a
verdict after two years of no collusion
with russia
you know during the very early part when
i came down the escalator with our great
first lady who by the way is very
popular
they love our first lady
i don't know that this speech will ever
end
but when i came down the escalator
it started early on young people would
come up you might have heard this story
i've told it a couple of times not much
but young campaign work sir it's such an
honor to meet you sir
oh
sir someday i want to be president sir
can i ask you one question yes do you
have anything to do with russia
i'd say that's a strange question from
this kid
then a month later somebody else would
come up sir it's an honor to meet you
sir do you have
anything at all or any knowledge of
anything that happened with you and
russia
no and i was so innocent you know it was
so crazy that i didn't even take it
seriously but after about the fifth time
this happened sir do you have anything
to do with i said
what the hell is going on with we are
beyond 90 minutes now tony story it was
a concocted story and it really started
as a way
to shift blame for the fact
that hillary clinton and the democrats
lost the election
but then it got carried away and the
press loved it and it kept going and
going
but
i tell this story with a very heavy
heart because i have a son who was a
very good guy don
very very good guy
he's a good kid he's a good person
sometimes he comes across a little rough
but you know what he's really he's just
a good person
and think of this
adam shifty schiff and these people they
made up this hoax they knew it was a
hoax
and i saw him at the microphones one day
saying donald trump jr the son of the
president of the united states
will soon be going to jail
for what he did with russia think of
this
he's saying that my son my beautiful son
my child
is going to go to jail
and he knew
it was a hoax wants to put my son
destroy my son and he knew do we think
trump knows the names of all his kids
these are evil people these are sick
people
think of them
right
kimberly
who has been through anything like this
certainly no politician and definitely
no president
all of this while i was doing so much as
president including creating the most
secure border in american history
record tax and regulation cuts
1.87 gasoline no inflation low interest
rates record growth in real wages record
growth in our economy
beating china and russia and everybody
else
rebuilding our entire military
rebuilt our entire military you know our
military was falling to peace we had no
bullets we have jet fighters that were
44 years old covered the story where the
grandfather flew him then the father
the historic abraham accords bringing
peace to the middle east
jerusalem and israel much much more
and now we have the january 6 unselect
committee of political hacks and thugs
like schiff
think of that though think about how
would you like to be a father and watch
this guy
not a stupid man he's a psycho but he's
not as stupid
and he does have an oddly shaped head of
shape like a watermelon
no he's a psycho
and he acts like so surrounded by
water
ladies and gentlemen i'm sorry to report
donald jr will be in jail for what he's
done and they and he knew it was
a hoax
what they do to destroy lives and
they're destroying the lives of many
other people right now with that same
thing and that same sickness and
thinking
but it's the very same people who
perpetrated the lies that i was
an agent of russia me i'm an agent
i'm the worst thing that ever happened
to putin look what he's doing now he's
knocking the hell out of everyone
because he has no respect that would
have never happened with me
would it never happen
it wasn't necessary with you i think i
had to listen to this you know with
russia
i put the biggest
i put the biggest charges on every one
of their people but what did i do i
stopped
i stopped gordstream too nobody ever
even heard the term nordstrom that was i
found out but i stopped them
and i stopped them why did i stop them
because i thought it was a terrible
thing for our country it was a terrible
thing for europe i told that to germany
they all smiled very famous now
germany was smiling when i was at the
united nations saying this is a terrible
thing all you have to do is look at the
last 200 years
it's going to happen again
we could end up in world war iii because
we are being governed by incompetent
people could happen
and this war will be worse than any war
ever because we have weapons the likes
of which nobody has ever seen before
but you say where does it stop where
does it end it probably doesn't stop
because despite great outside dangers
our biggest threat remains the sick
sinister and evil people from within our
own country
never forget everything this corrupt
establishment is doing to me
is all about preserving their power and
control over the american people
they want to damage me in any form so
that i can no longer represent the
hard-working
citizens of our country
so that i will no longer get a 99
approval rating
from cpac
this is a dumb speech even by trump
standards
i heard matt protest that he said it
can't be it came out at 98 this is a
story i don't know if it's true but matt
will tell you someday he protested he
said that's ridiculous can't be so they
went back and they checked all the facts
and it went from 98 to 99. is that a
true story
and that was mclaughlin you know that's
a great legit firm that was mclaughlin
he said can't be that's too hard it
doesn't look right
we'll check it again 99
but they don't like that the other side
doesn't like that much man
and the fake news media is totally
complicit in all of these things that
are happening if i renounced my beliefs
if i agreed to stay silent if i stayed
home or if i stayed in my basement
the
persecution of donald trump would stop
immediately
that's what they want me to do but i
can't do that and i will not do that
because i love our country and i love
the people
of our country so much
thank you
i'm not doing this for me
because i had a very good and luxurious
life
you know that carrie i had a very
luxurious life what the hell did i do
i got a racist attorney general in new
york that's been after me for years
she campaigned on the fact i will get
donald trump she doesn't know anything
about me i will get him
terrible people these are terrible
people i built a great company now
they're finding out this was a great
company great company actually better
than they thought much better
but i do it for you and it's my honor
to do it it's my great honor to do it
because if i don't our nation is doomed
to become another venezuela or becoming
of the soviet union which is where we're
headed what a martial become a very
large-scale version of cuba
where all is lost and there is no hope
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radicals
we are fighting against may be no matter
how menacing they appear we must never
forget that this nation does not belong
to them
this nation
belongs
to you
this is your home this is your heritage
this is your country that your american
ancestors means this is the one with
their own courage
defended with their own blood and built
with their own hands
from the jagged peaks
of the rocky mountains
to the gleaming waters of the great
lakes from the majestic valleys of
california to the beautiful hill country
of texas
from the stark prairies
of the great plains to the banks
of the rio grande
which is under siege also isn't it
and from the magnificent skyscrapers of
new york and chicago and l.a
to the beauty right here
of the storied alamo
we inherit the legacy of generations
of american patriots he's been speaking
for 100 minutes imagine that
that they loved
they scaled the summits they forged the
rivers
they crossed the sweltering deserts
brave blistering winters
conquered an unknown wilderness
and settled
the great frontier
they laid down the railroads
they built out the highways
and they turned tiny villages towering
into great magnificent buildings of iron
and steel
like nobody had ever seen before
they did it all to make america into the
greatest and most
exceptional nation
in the history of the world
but now
we are a nation in decline
we are a failing nation
we are a nation that is
hurting very very badly
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in over 40 years
and where the stock market just finished
the worst first half of the year since
1872 up like 11 in the last five weeks
that has the highest energy cost in its
history
we are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant
as we were just too short
years ago
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela
saudi arabia
and many others for oil
please please please help us joe biden
says
and yet we have more liquid gold right
under our feet
than any other country in the world
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical left's green new deal
yet everyone knows that the green new
deal
will lead to our
destruction
we're a nation that surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers american
citizens
and 85 billion dollars worth of the
finest
military equipment in the world and we
are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse
it would never have happened with me as
your commander-in-chief
and for four long years it didn't
and china
with taiwan
is next
would also
never have happened we are a nation that
has
weaponized its law enforcement
like never before against
the opposing political party
we are a nation that no longer has a
free press
at this point i'm genuinely curious how
long he can go
and they are the enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech
is no longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been
collapsing
at a rate that few have ever seen
where more people died of covet in 2021
then died in 2020.
we're a nation that is allowing iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon
which they are incredibly being allowed
to do right now and i had it stopped
and china to use the trillions and
trillions of dollars it has taken from
us prior to
our administration
and it's happening again
to build a military
that will more than
rival our own
and just two years ago we had iran
china russia and north korea and czech
and they weren't going to do a thing
against us
and everyone knows it and perhaps most
importantly we are a nation that is no
longer respected or listened to around
the world
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
we are a nation that is hostile to
liberty freedom and faith we are a
nation that allows
men to play sports
on women's teams
and to dominate them
we are a nation whose airports are a
disaster whose flights never leave on
time
and whose passengers are stranded all
over the country
we are in many ways a third world nation
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering whose supply chain is broken
whose stores are not stocked
whose deliveries are not coming
and who's anybody still alive in the
chat out there let me know every single
list
but we are not going to let this
continue
two years ago we had the greatest
in our nation
we had something that was so incredible
we had the greatest people in our nation
fighting
like they've never fought before they
had spirit
they had hope
but we will soon have that greatness
again
you will soon have that greatness again
all right
america's comeback begins this november
and it will continue onward with the
unstoppable momentum
that we're going to develop
on november
2024 because that's going to be that's
the big one
we are going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting
we are going to keep on winning and we
are going to get our country back
as long as we can
not lose our spirit
our movement will never be defeated this
is the greatest movement
mega this is the greatest movement in
the history of our country
greatest in the history of our country
there's never been anything like it
probably you could say it's
the greatest or one of the greatest in
the history of the world and it's
interesting because sometimes i'll make
a comment and i'll be challenged
so strongly by the fake news
but they never even challenged me on
that i've never been challenged i look
at them right now a lot of
we are over
105 minutes movement in the history of
our country by far
and it will only get stronger with each
passing day
and with the help of all of you here
tonight and the millions of patriots all
across our land
we will make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america
proud again
we will make america
safe again
and we will make america great again
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much god bless you all
really sprinting to the finish line
there huh
[Music]
well an exhausting
and meandering speech from donald trump
hitting most of the highlights the
overtly transphobic portion of the
speech
the dictatorial part of the speech
the humiliating part of the speech i
mean really hitting
hitting all of it
um
oh there's some people here we might
actually
[Music]
someone who's kind of annoying me in the
chat we're gonna ban them
when in doubt
bam that's my uh that's my perspective
at this point
uh well
there it is
another cpac in the books
trump's sort of uh wandering backstage
after
delivering a very strange screed
there he is
calling for the elimination of the
department of education
this is not a crowd anyone would mistake
for being big fans
of education that's for sure
[Music]
all right
okay everybody well thank you for
joining me it is the end of cpac texas
2022
uh the vendors are now allowed to take
down their displays
and to get the hell out of texas that is
what is going on now
thank you to everyone everyone everyone
who joined me
thanks to kyoko who says i was very
shocked to learn through your show that
cpac has a branch in japan
they do to my relief it's a tiny group
of few wacky people not much going on
hope it stays that way yeah it's uh
pretty scary stuff
all right everybody we will see
everybody this week we have major
coverage coming of breaking issues over
54 countries have now been taken by the
machines that is exactly right we will
talk about the machine takeover we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines without a doubt all right
everybody see you monday
you